the gloriously colourful and glitter
filled world of trolls gets a whole lot
bigger in trolls world tour when poppy
and branch discover there are six troll
tribes including the fearsome rock
trolls left by hard rocker Queen barb
yippie KY may be lovers I'm Jan and in
this video i'm revealing over 50 amazing
hidden details Easter eggs and secrets
packed into the brand-new troll sequel
and keep watching to learn how you can
win one of these incredible official
movie merch packs when Queen Barb and
her hard rock crew gatecrashed the
techno trolls underwater rave they
arrive in some scary-looking critters
called angler buses the design of the
angler bus is based on the real-life
angler fish an ambush predator often
found in the murky depths of the sea up
to a mile below the surface using that
particular fish as inspiration for the
rock trolls transport was a great choice
by the filmmakers because angler fish
are usually dark and have loads of sharp
teeth in their enormous mouths which can
expand to swallow prey up to twice as
big as their bodies and all of that of
course perfectly fits the hard rock
trolls terrifying vibe as well as their
punk rock style with all its dark
leather denim and metal spikes and studs
throwing Barb's crazy train song we see
the angler buses burst out of the ocean
and drive around madly on land while she
rocks out well tour director Walt dawn
has said this scene was inspired by the
huge chase sequence of Mad Max fury road
which included crazy drummers and rock
guitarists playing on some insane and
gargantuan vehicles while speeding
across the land just like the first film
the animation controls world tour is
astounding and there's such an
incredibly tactile textured quality to
both movies that you feel you could
almost reach out and touch it in all its
fealty fuzziness and right from the
start there's loads of lovely little
visual details the underwater Empire of
the techno trolls mixes the digital
world of techno with the homemade
textiles we see in many of the other
troll lands which means we not only get
lasers LEDs and trolls with fiber optic
hair glow paint patterns skin an 8-bit
beating hearts but we also get
landscapes made of crochet and macrame
that's the art of making things using
knots and the way the neon color
crowd moves at first draws on the
natural world mimicking the motion of a
wave in the sea which is a nice touch
given they live underwater bursts as the
songs about to reach its peak things
look more digital and the way they move
takes on the look of a spectrum analyzer
on a home stereo when it comes to the
film's title if you look closely at the
fiery flames beneath it you'll see that
they look like bright orange strands of
troll hair as for the waterfall in the
pop troll kingdom that's made of long
narrow strips of shiny tinsel and the
lonesome dusty world of the country
trolls is filled with buildings shaped
like patchwork quilted cacti roads made
of burlap and when you see the farmland
from above it looks like an enormous
multicolored patchwork quilt the
filmmakers wanted to make the big chase
scene where Hickory in the pop trolls
are run out of town feel like how kids
play with their troll toys at home on
their bedspreads so they decided to make
the cliff they fall down out of a stack
of quilts and folded blankets and did
you notice how crucial vinyl records are
in the design of the funk trolls home
not only is the room where they keep
their tribes musical string full of
columns made out of Records but the
outside of their spaceship is mostly
made out of silver records also instead
of the scrapbooks that tell the pop
trolls pop washed version of troll
history when Prince details poppy the
real history of the six tribes visually
the stories told using the cover art of
a double album the little gem that the
classical trolls have on their tummies
is a lovely tribute to the 1990s toys
called treasure trolls that had a little
jewel in their belly button which you
could make a wish on in fact there was
already a reference to those particular
troll toys in the trolls holiday special
good luck troll day put a jam the leader
the classical trolls is called trolls
art which is a play on the name of the
famous classical music composer Mozart
who like his trolls world tour
counterparts was also often pictured
wearing a white wig keeping with the
classical theme of symphony ville if you
listen very closely you can hear the
tribes critters all bleating the word
bark which is a pun on the name of the
renowned classical music composer
mixed with the usual bar sound made by
sheep or goats Owen if you look closely
at the animals design - you'll see their
legs even look like little musical notes
world tour also has many callbacks and
similarities to the first trolls movie
oh I can start the feeling bar band the
Hard Rock trolls invade the techno troll
Kingdom just as they're in the middle of
a huge rave party similar to the first
movie in how the Bergen chef found the
trolls in the forest when poppy threw a
big party and when Cooper poops out a
three-tier cake with candles after he's
terrified by some weird and wonderful
creatures her Bluebird breath it's a
callback to how he was so scared that he
pooped out cupcakes when chef invaded
the troll Kingdom in the first film
taptic and if you keep watching through
the movie's credits you'll see those
strange creatures gobble up Cooper's
cake also in the credits is a cata bus
similar to the wand controls holiday and
like so much of the strange fairytale
like dream quality of the trolls
franchise the various weird critters the
trolls use for transport are a great
deal - the odd creatures and dreamlike
world's created by renowned Japanese
writer director Hayao Miyazaki who
co-founded Studio Ghibli and gave us
such classic animated movies as My
Neighbor Totoro which features the
iconic cat bus ok spoilers ahead for the
ending of the movie now you can skip to
the time on screen to avoid them if you
prefer another callback in world tour is
when the six strings are destroyed all
the trials will lose their colour
similar to how the trolls faded to gray
in the original movie when they were
trapped and thought they were about to
be eaten by the Bergin's in the sequel
the trolls color begins to return when
cooper notices his own heartbeat and
that the music is still inside him we
see his heart glow and slowly bit by bit
each of the other trials hearts also
lights up as they sing and their colour
returns to them the fact that music is
in the trolls hearts and not the strings
was hinted at several times earlier with
many heart patterns and symbols
appearing throughout the movie from the
thumping heartbeat in the opening scene
two heart symbols on the chest of the
techno trolls the heart-shaped bubbles
they blow and the explosion of digital
hearts when King troll X drops the beat
to the pop trolls heart formation during
the opening medley then there's the
heart shape the classical trolls and the
country trolls form when playing the
heart shaped glasses that poppy branch
and Biggie were when they perform in
Lonesome flats Chaz's heart-shaped chest
hair and the heart pattern he blows with
the petals from a saxophone and when the
funk trolls sing it's all love some of
the spinning records light up and pulse
in a heart shaped pattern if you enjoyed
watching the bergens in the first movie
in the holiday short then you'll be glad
that even though they don't have a
starring role this time they at least
get a little cameo in the new film after
poppy and branch fly off together during
the movies credits Queen Bridget and
King gristle pop up in a quick
mid-credits scene where we find out that
they're disappointed to have missed out
on all the fun
Oh Chrissie I guess we're late to the
party Oh balls
ready but who's gonna eat my cheese
balls babe the fathers are many other
troll tribes we get to meet some brand
new popped roles including legs Lee who
has extendable legs meaning she can go
from short to tall very quickly unlike
the other trolls so she can't extend and
manipulate her hair and there's a nod to
this when the pop trolls use their hair
as legs to dance about during their
opening song
oh and by the way legs Lee which
definitely feels like a limb based burn
on the name Leslie is voiced by the
Acker awesome singer-songwriter
Esther Dean thanks Pappy Garth
who's not only written masses of hits
for the likes of Rihanna and Katy Perry
but she also played Bardem Bella Cynthia
Rose in the pitch perfect movies
alongside poppy voice actress Anna
Kendrick another new pop trollish
skyscraper who like legs Lee is also the
opposite of many of the other pop trolls
because he's a first link style troll
who has an enormous body of her all the
way down to his feet but unlike fellow
firstlings such as first Bert who have
no head or face skyscraper has four
heads all of which speak in unison yeah
differently be and skyscraper is voiced
by the podcasting McElroy brothers who
campaign to appear in World Tour
after they discovered youtubers add
voiced characters in the first movie
each brother also voiced additional
characters with Justin playing the parts
of Beach drop button and tumbleweed use
snap with Griffin voicing country music
tear while Travis did raucous here when
the snack pack goes undercover to
infiltrate the rock trolls they each
were outfits and designs referencing
icons rock and roll we need to go
undercover about how with fashion biggie
and dinkles each take on a different
look from Elvis Presley legs Lee has a
black and white striped outfit that
references Elvis's jailhouse rock and
Saturn and Chanel's clothes and red and
white pom-poms and knots the
cheerleaders in the musical movie Grease
now what did you enjoy most about trolls
world tour and who are your favorite new
characters leave your thoughts and
comments below and before you go I've
got several packs of official trolls
world tour merchandise to give away make
sure you subscribe and follow the link
in the video description or pinned
comment for a chance to win you can also
tap left to watch my full trolls
playlist including amazing deleted
scenes or tap right for something else
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time you pick a movie
lovers